Just spoke to the USC football team,
and I said something in there
that really caught my attention.
I said something.. I'm sure
you'll edit it and make it fly,
because that's how
you do it D-Rock.
For 80 or 90% of you,
this is going to be the best.
This is gonna be as good as it gets.
This is the prime.
This is the best.
And this rant is about timing.
You need to be aware of when
you have your big opportunities.
You need to squeeze so fucking hard
when you've got that moment.
You have to understand that
shit will always change.
If it's terrible right now,
it's going to get better.
If it is phenomenal right now,
it is going to get worse.
That is just the way it's always been.
I'm not smart.
It's just fucking history.
So please, if you take anything
out of this mini little rant for DRock,
it's about timing.
Recognize your moments and strike.
That has absolutely been the
foundation of my success,
whether it was selling my baseball
cards when I just felt it,
whether it was the internet itself.
Whether it was other things like
starting Vaynermedia when I
had all these other opportunities,
but I wanted to triple down to my
strengths during this Golden era.
Sometimes they're fun,
sometimes they're taking
a step back "in theory".
But it's all about knowing
when to go all-in
and the one thing we get is regret when
we didn't squeeze our best opportunity.
So when you're a football player at USC,
that is a big-time fucking opportunity
because most of you don't
go to the league and
most of you aren't successful
in the league, and this is your apex.
Whether you're a manager in a store right now,
whether you're a great student in high school,
whether you're awfully pretty right now,
but you know you're not
going to be as pretty one day.
I'm being serious now.
I know this is silly shit.
But when you have your best situation,
when you have the fucking leverage,
you need to fucking strike.
When you don't, you don't pout:  You
put in the work to rebuild your next leverage.
I had YouTube. I had Twitter.
When they weren't as big anymore,
I didn't cry that Instagram or Snapchat came.
I put in the work to build myself back
up and matter in that ecosystem,
and now that I got
the Instagram moment again,
I'm fucking pounding.
I'm pounding harder than I did
the last time because I learned
because when pattern recognition
from experience, you get better.
If this can inspire you...
If your shit's good right now,
quadruple down.
If it's not, stay quiet
and build and look for
that moment when you
know it's good. Pound!
Because squeezing, when you have
the opportunity, is the key.